وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه تناسب تجريبيه
الناجحه لمركبتها الفضائيه غير الماهوله
اوليون تطمح ناس من خلال برنامج ارتميس
الى ارسال رحلات ماهوله باستخدام تقنيات
مبتكره لتاسيس اول وجود طويل الامد على
سطح القمر واكدت ان عودتها الى القمر تهدف
الى الحفاظ على رياده الامريكيه في
الاستكشاف من خلال التعاون مع شركاءات
تجاريين فالفضاء لم يعد حكرا على الدول
تتنافس فيها ايضا شركات خاصه تقوم بتغيير
اقتصاديات الفضاء من خلال ارسال رحلات
ماهوله الى الفضاء ورحلات سياحيه ايضا
فضلا عن ارسال بعثات الى كوكب المريخ
في اوائل العام الجاري من المتوقع ان تهبط
مركبتان بنتهما شركات خاصه على سطح القمر
ستحمل المركبتين عربات جواله وتجارب الى
سطح القمر بعضها قد يساعد في تعبيد الطريق
الى عوده رواد الفضاء في سبتمبر ايلول
المقبل من المتوقع ان تعيد المركبه
الفضائيه وسير استيركس التابعه لناس عينات
من كويكب بعيد الى الارض التقطت المركبه
الفضائيه الركامه من الكويت بينو في
اكتوبر عام 2020 وستكون اولا مهمه للناس
لاعاده عينه من الكويتب اختيار الكويكب
بنولي انه يعتقدوا ان مادته الغنيه
بالكربون تحتوي على العناصر الاساسيه
المحفوظه لنظامنا الشمسيه وهو ما قد يساعد
العلماء على فهم افضل لكيفيه تشكل الكواكب
منذ مليارات السنين في اكتوبر تشرين الاول
المقبل من المتوقع ان تطلق ناسا مهمتها
سايكي والتي ستسافر الى كويكب فريد غني
بالم النادره يدور حول الشمس بين المريخ
والمشتري
يعتقد ان الكويكب يحتوي على ما يكفي من
الذهب لجعل كل شخص على الارض مليار‬»
ماسك لاطلاق مركبه فضائيه غير ماهوله
للوصول الى الكويتب كما تعاقدت مع شركه
ستار شيب التابعه لماسك لانزال روادها على
القمر عام 2025 او نحو ذلك في اول هبوط
للقمر منذ ابنه